[Music]
buckle up
because the love triangle between olivia
rodrigo sabrina carpenter and joshua
bassett just got
even wilder you're putting me in the
spotlight
but i've been under it all my life yeah
so on thursday night sabrina dropped
that song called skin and now fans think
the song was written
in response to olivia rodrigo's song
driver's license
[Music]
just to get you up to speed earlier this
month olivia released
that emotional bop and fans were quick
to point out that the lyrics appear to
be about her high school musical the
musical the series co-star and rumor dex
joshua
leaving her for his alleged new boo
sabrina carpenter
and you're probably with that blind girl
who always made me doubt
she's so much older than me she's
everything i'm insecure
about uh-huh that blonde girl
she's older she made me doubt sabrina
she's blonde and 21 four years older
than olivia
okay now fast forward to thursday and
sabrina's new track maybe we could have
been friends
if i met you in another life maybe then
we could pretend there's no gravity in
the words we write
maybe you didn't mean it maybe blonde
was the only
rhyme maybe blonde was the only rhyme
i'm dead deceased bye but that wasn't
the only clue that this could all be a
giant clap back
[Music]
yep so there's that and there's this
ouch but the most damning line of all
just take a listen don't drive yourself
inside
yeah drive yourself driver's license
you be the judge i think one of the
things that i've really learned from
olivia is the um the storytelling aspect
of songwriting and i think that i you
know i'm more of like a
this is how i feel in this moment and
she really does a job of like
telling a story and putting you in that
time and place and i think that
that's been super um inspiring to me and
has definitely influenced
my music but i definitely think that we
we kind of we
uh you know we grow from each other
while olivia and josh never confirmed an
off-screen romance
fans believe the two dated before
breaking up last year
then photos of josh hanging out with
sabrina surfaced
and the two even dressed as sharkboy and
lava girl for halloween
close your eyes shut your mouth dream a
dream and get us
out dream dream dream dream dream dream
oh and josh he dropped his own track
titled
lie lie lie just days after olivia
released hers
[Music]
and while the lyrics sound like they
could also be a response to olivia's
song
josh actually performed a demo of lila
lie on instagram
back in november 2019 before their
rumored 2020 split
so far no one has addressed the drama
directly but
one thing's for sure they are bringing
us some
[Music]
bops
you